let me then start by introducing
our first speaker vijay ganesh who is
also an
organizer uh you may
know vj as the person behind maplestart
which was award-winning
still award-winning uh solver at
the competitions or you may know him as
the person who proved decidabilities of
some interesting theories
uh vijay is in the university of
waterloo the phd at mit
and just one thing to say uh he has a
paper with 1400 citation which is
to put it in perspective 400 more than
gokuraka
okay without further ado vijay the floor
is yours
okay um you small mistake i did my phd
at stanford
and i was working as a scientist at mit
but that's okay
um thank you antonina for your kind
introduction so today i will be talking
about
perspectives on the practice and theory
of sat solving
and in fact i will
start by talking about perhaps the
central question and sat and smt solving
which is the
unreasonable effectiveness of these
solvers for many classes of industrial
instances
and at the same time these solvers
happen to be slow on
other classes of industrial instances
such as crypto
and that's the theme of the entire
workshop
and at the end of my talk i will go
through
the set of talks that we have
scheduled already for the first nine
weeks to give you an
overview of what you're going to learn
and how you know interact with
the speakers the kind of speakers that
you would interact with
so uh and then i will talk about
structural view of industrial instances
the
current best understanding and what are
the pitfalls in this kind of research
final then i'll present a view of
solvers
as combinations of proof systems and
machine learning heuristics
some separation results for con solver
configurations
leveraging solvers for theory open
problems and directions and then
workshop talks so let me jump into it
let me start with the context and
motivation
namely the central question and solving
so why are solvers
efficient they don't have a right to be
efficient
if you were to believe the
predictions from worst case complexity
however they are efficient so which
means that there is clearly a gap
between
the map complexity theory and territory
and the goal here
is to bridge that gap but not only the
is our goal to bridge the gap deepen our
theoretical understanding
but also perhaps from my perspective
equally interesting
is to come up with better solver design
that will
last a long time and fortunately
complexity theories have developed a
variety of tools that we can leverage
in order to bridge this gap one of them
being parameterized complexity
and as i mentioned earlier uh there are
classes of instances for which we know
uh solvers on which solvers take a long
time
so what is the reason uh as to why
solvers take a long time on such classes
of instances
and many of these questions have been
open for a couple of decades
and this question is important not only
in the context of sad but it's actually
a general question and
to the extent that i know many other
this question is relevant in the context
of many other formal reasoning systems
such as
cp solvers qbf solvers model checkers
smt solvers
so this is basically an endless amount
of work uh
and a very large class of interesting
problems
to to uh solve
and of course this extends to many other
settings where practical algorithms
seem to defy theoretical expectations
set by worst case analysis
and many researchers including richard
carpen others have suggested this is one
of the most important problems
in the context of algorithm design and
complexity
so how do we break this question down
into smaller questions
so i'm going to assume that most of the
speakers are already quite familiar with
cdcl solvers
and also familiar with proof systems and
the connection between solvers and
proof systems and i urge you to go and
uh
listen to the excellent boot camp talks
by sam bus and others
if you haven't already done that so with
that background
what how do we break this question down
so the context
in which we'll be working is that it's
known that cdcl solvers are polynomially
equivalent
to general resolutions the famous result
by sirius
victor thoroughly in 2011 or
independently by pipachi savart and
darvish
so while this equivalence is great
meaning that now i can
lift uh lower bounds from proof
complexity onto sat solvers
the trouble is that it doesn't quite
answer the question as to why solvers
are efficient on some classes of
instances
it also doesn't address the question of
the crypto instances that i mentioned
earlier
because all the lower bounds that i know
of in the context of resolution
are you know crafted instances if you
will they're the kind of artificial
instances so
so can we kind of break this question
down into smaller questions
of why solvers are in uh efficient
and uh when when you run a solver on an
instance and if it
and let's say the instance is unset and
the solver runs quickly on that instance
we can make two conclusions from that
one is that the unsight formula has a
short proof
for otherwise it would not end quickly
and the second
thing is that the proof search was easy
meaning that
the proof was short and the solvers were
able to find the short proof
now observe that this is not necessarily
always the case
but it is the case for industrial
instances so
then the question becomes what kind of
formula structure or parameters and
range of values to these parameters
result in short proofs for unset
formulas and why is it
possible for cdcl solvers to find such
short proofs efficiently
that is they are automatable under
appropriate parameterization
there has been a recent interesting
result that says resolution is not
automatable
unless p equal to np so just to reflect
on this point a little bit if you
haven't heard about automatability
before the idea is this so imagine that
in a proof system
for a particular class of formulas you
do have happen to have short proofs
it is still possible that there does not
exist an algorithm under appropriated
assumptions
that would be able to find uh these
short proofs in it
in a in a time polynomial in the size of
the proof
so therefore uh the fact that
industrial sat solvers are able to find
these proofs efficiently means that we
have to somehow
be able to account for that through the
lens of say parameterization that's one
possible way we could
account for it so
making this a bit more concrete what
would be the kind of target conjectures
that
we should aim for so i'll state these
conjectures
and then the entire research program is
aimed
at you know we work backwards from these
conjectures and it's aimed at proving
these conjectures
so the first set of conjectures is we
want to have parameters
upper bounds uh for the cdcl algorithm
so one possibility is
you know the traditional parameterized
complexity upper bound like 2 to the
function of parameters times
polynomial in the size of the input for
appropriate values
of real-world parameters so it's very
important that these parameters be
real-world
and what i mean by that is that these
parameters should capture
structure witnessed in industrial
instances for otherwise
it's not that interesting it's good to
have such a result but
it doesn't quite explain what's going on
in cdcl set source or doesn't even
attempt to explain
the other possibility is that you may
have something similar to
an eth style result meaning
that it's 2 to the 1 minus 1 over k
times n just like in the case of ppse
except now instead of k which is the
clause width in the case of ppse we have
some real word parameters or some
functional real-world parameters
up there so it's like 2 to the epsilon n
and also we want to pare it down into
not just
parameterize upper bound on the running
time of the solver but
also proof search and proof size we
want better practically inspired lower
bound for resolution
uh for example crypto why is crypto hard
and we want better
understanding of solver configuration so
observe the following
a solver is a collection of heuristics
and i can switch these heuristics on and
off for example restarts
and every time i switch them on and off
we do witness
a dramatic change in performance
in the case of certain heuristics and
why is that
and this is like and you can play this
endless game and you can have
a very large number of solver
configurations and you can ask the
question
uh is the cdcl sat solver with without
restarts
a strictly weaker proof system relative
to cdcl sats over
with restarts or is it probably the case
that restarts only influence proofs
proof search or maybe both
we don't know the answer as yet and of
course all of this has to lead to
better solver design especially stronger
proof systems and better ways to
sequence select and initialize proof
rules
all right so now i'm going to talk about
what we
know i'm going to just give you an
overview of what we know about
parameters and empirical understanding
of solvers for our parameters
so given that this problem has been well
known for some time
uh theorists and practitioners have
proposed
a variety of parameters in order to
explain what's really going on
parameters such as tree width community
structure backdoor etc so the goal here
or the kind of the premise is that
the industrial instances have some
structure that is exploited by solver
and the goal here is to then
explain the part of the solver in terms
of these
structural parameters and the goal of
the
empirical work in this context is to
either
rule out certain parameters or rule in
certain parameters for further
theoretical analysis
but as i will state in a few minutes we
can never conclusively rule out a rule
in anything
so i'll make that clear in a minute
so we want to have these parameters we
want to discover parameters that
withstand a battery of well-designed
empirical tests
that are primed for further analysis but
the problem with empirical analysis is
it can never be conclusive or complete
because experiments are inherently
contingent on many
factors such as sample size solver
setting tools used etc
so because of all this you have to kind
of take it with a grain of salt
but we can i think say things like
uh based on the work that we have done
hypothesis a is stronger than hypothesis
b
so what are the properties that we
expect these parameters must
possess the first property must be that
we must be able to witness the structure
that we are parameterizing
in real world instances so in other
words parameters must be able to
differentiate we should be able to
differentiate between
industrial instances random instances
crypto instances etc
just by looking at this parameterization
somehow
for example build a machine learning
classifier
for appropriate range of values for
these parameters
we should be able to show there exists a
correlation between
these parameters and solve a running
time put differently
parameters should be useful as features
in empirical hardness models
and finally uh we want to be able to
generate instances scale these
parameters
and witness the the runtime behavior
and validate our hypothesis in this
manner
and if you pass these battery of tests
then we pass it over to
theories or work with theories to prove
you know meaningful theorems
so have we ruled out certain parameters
one could say
that is a yes at least for some
parameters
so in the 1990s there was a lot of
excitement
uh with the clause variable ratio
parameter which
i'm sure all of you have heard of so
it's just the ratio of the total number
of clauses in a formula divided by the
total number of variables
and it was with was seen that uh for
three sat
there's a phase transition phenomena uh
when the cvr
is 4.26 for randomly
generated formulas by randomly generated
formulas i mean that
the clauses are generally uniform at
random
and also there was it was seen that
there is an easy hard easy pattern here
exactly at the phase transition so the
the phase transition is where
to the let's say to the left of the
phase transition when the cvr is less
than 4.26 most of the formulas are
are satisfiable to the right most of
them are unset and further
the hardest instances are exactly at
this transition
but it was later shown that this does
not quite hold up under scaling studies
and it also doesn't kind of lift to
industrial instances
yet another parameter which is very
natural and very nice
is tree width and the kind of the key in
inside behind tree with this
you take up the graph of a formula and
check how tree-like it is
and the hypothesis here is that the more
tree-like it is the easier it would be
for the solver to solve such instances
so it's a really cool idea in fact many
theorems have been proven
uh with regard to related concepts such
as branch width and path width
which are polynomially related to tree
with and the graph that i'm talking
about here is the variable incidence
graph of the boolean formula
where variables correspond to nodes and
if two variables are in the same clause
then they're connected by an edge
uh it was shown in 2011 that tree with
does not correlate with solver runtime
that is to mean that uh we expect that
when tree width is small the formula
would be easy to solve
however it was shown that uh
easy formula section have large tree
width and hard formulas
there exist hard formulas that have
small treatment so this doesn't quite
cut it
and pathway and branch without also have
been proposed that as i mentioned
earlier and they
are polynomially related to true bits so
we can also rule them out for
similar reasons yet another class of
parameters are backdoors and here i'm
citing a thesis by my student where
he worked on checking whether back doors
are indeed
explanatory and backdoors were
introduced by ryan williams
salman and gomes uh to the extent that i
know
back in 2003 as a possible explanation
for the
these power of dpll solvers
and uh but we were able to show that
there are instances
that are small backdoor that are hard to
solve and large factor that are easy to
solve
yet another class of instances another
class of
parameters is community structure
parameters that have been proposed
and while they're empirically very
interesting it's quite easy to show
that you you can easily construct
formulas
that have good community structure and
yet we can prove
that they will be very hard to solve and
you can also show empirically that
they're hard to solve
so yeah so the nut the
bottom line here is that the parameters
are intuitive easy to work with
theoretically but they fall apart
upon contact with reality so here are
some parameters
to the extent that i know have not yet
been ruled out
and many of them have worked
i've worked with many of these
parameters so one of them is merged and
i will talk about it in a minute it's a
generalization of the idea of
subsumption
yet another parameter is hierarchical
community structure that we came up with
recently
which is a variant of community
structure and the good thing about the
hierarchical community structure idea is
that
it does not suffer from at least kind of
the obvious counter examples
that one could think of the other
parameter that
also we're considering is power law or
more generally
uh the the degree of variable
occurrences
and we know that the degree of variable
occurrences is highly unbalanced
in the case of industrial instances but
not so in the case of random and
uh crypto instances so what do i mean by
highly unbalanced uh it's that few
variables occur very often but most
other variables
occur rarely or very few times relative
to
these highly occurring variables
so i'll focus on merge for a moment
and there is a resolution proof system
called merge resolution
and the basic idea behind this merge
resolution proof system is that it is
biased towards
performing resolution over clauses that
share literals
and the idea is that imagine you have
two clauses one is alpha or xn and the
other one is negation of xn or alpha
for the moment just forget those dots in
there and then
you're going to derive alpha which is
strictly smaller than the input
clauses so this kind of merging of
literals is kind of nice because you are
guaranteed to get shorter clauses
provided you have two non-unit clauses
input with the property that i mentioned
but even if
they don't overlap completely you know
over time a lot of mergers
are likely to give shorter clauses and a
particular form of merge
is the subsumption resolution wherein
the derived clause subsumes one of the
input clauses
and we have noticed we have observed
that such
subsumption resolution occurs a lot
in the case of industrial instances
although more thorough
work needs to be done there
so so i just kind of
told you how merge can enable you to get
shorter clauses i'm not going to belabor
that with this particular example here
let me skip over this and kind of get to
the kind of instant scaling experiment
that we performed
in order to validate our hypothesis the
merge has something to do with
uh the performance of cdcl on some class
of instances
so here in this experiment what we did
was we generated about
i think 500 or so uh
pseudo-industrial instances using a
popularity generality
as a popularity similarity uh uh
generator which is believed to generate
instances similar to industrial
instances
and uh attempted to keep while keeping
all other
aspects of ins the instance the same we
would vary the merge
parameter now how do we do that what we
do is we
use transformations that allow us to
either increase or decrease the number
of
overlaps between resolvable clauses and
we
define a metric called mergibility which
simply counts
the number of overlapping literals in a
formula between resolvable
pairs and the y-axis you can see
uh the number of merges deviating from
the mean so zero is
the mean and as you go towards the right
you increase the number of merges as you
go towards the left you decrease the
number of merges
and what we notice is that during the
run of the solver
when you when you have an input formula
that has a lot of merges in it
the average loan clause size is much
smaller
compared to when there are few merges
and further uh this we also perform this
similar experiment with solver runtime
and we see a dramatic
decrease in solver runtime as the merge
mergeability metric is increased
so this gives us confidence that this
particular metric
might be relevant and additionally
as i mentioned earlier subsumption
resolution seems like a
a very uh is a is a
rule that gets applied again and again
in the context of industrial instances
so uh perhaps this might be one of the
metrics
uh that would go into a theorem uh to
prove
uh appropriate parameters upper bounds
now uh so so far i've talked about
parameters
and not referenced internals of the
solver
and here i'm going to shift gears a
little bit and i'm going to
think about uh how can i leverage ideas
from theory
in practice and you know theorists have
modeled
solvers as proof systems and i started
thinking when i
first started working in the context of
sat
this is great but you know how do i
leverage this because if you were to
open up a sat solver and look at inside
of it
it's a veritable soup of heuristics
over time i came up with this idea that
you know one could model solvers
as combinations of proof systems and
machine learning and this is actually a
very nice combination because
solvers generate a lot of data and
machine learning
literature is full of optimization
heuristics that we can leverage
uh in this context
so um yeah so just to reiterate that
you know solvers are proof search
systems and it's a well-known
abstraction but we kind of
modify it a little bit by adding this
element uh of machine learning
heuristics
and i'll make it a bit more precise what
i mean by adding machine learning
heuristics but i want to contrast that
for a moment with sat solvers that are
non-symbolic that is they don't do any
kind of symbolic reasoning
uh for example once based on purely deep
neural networks like neurosat
and we know that these solvers don't
scale very well
so uh the obvious way in which
you can use the saw proof system
abstraction for solvers to
improve them is to add stronger proof
rules in your solver
and that's kind of the basic idea behind
cdclt
but the method that i proposed
was that if you think of a solver
it's essentially a decision procedure
but internally it's an optimization
procedure where the goal is to
construct the shortest proof possible
and
one way to construct short proofs is to
optimally sequence
or select proof rules from a set of
rules and
we can use machine learning uh towards
that end
so just to remind you of the cdcl sat
solver
how it works it takes its input and
input as
a boolean formula performs boolean
constraint propagation on it
until it reaches a fixed point either
it correctly decides input or it cannot
make progress
checks whether the formula is
unsatisfying under the current partial
assignment
if not it branches on a variable and
keeps propagating
until it gets a conflict so there is a
process here where
you are using bcp followed by branching
until you get a conflict and when you
get a conflict the conflict analysis
gets triggered so there is
another process so there are two
processes going on inside the solver
and this suggests the following idea
you could think of this as reinforcement
learning so you have an agent
which is the decision heuristic plus bcp
that performs
propagations and construct a partial
assignment until such time that you get
a conflict at which point it gives it to
an environment
and the environment then reasons about
what's going on
and returns back to the agent a reward
in terms of a loan clause and
then the branching heuristic can then
use that to make better decisions going
forward
so we modeled this as a reinforcement
learning problem
in particular in a multi-unbanded
problem and we
leveraged algorithms from the
reinforcement learning literature
to design the lrb branching heuristic
which is the basis for
maple sad and since we introduced this
in 2016
many if not most of the winning solvers
are based off of maple syrup
and subsequent to that we have you come
up with six
other heuristics aimed at different
aspects of the solver
and machine learning heuristics
and uh and other people have adopted and
adapted of these ideas
another result that i would like to talk
about here
uh there is a chat you have five more
minutes
okay uh i may take a couple of more
minutes uh
that's okay uh understanding cdcl solver
configurations
so uh there is a big open question we
know that cdcl
sat solvers with restarts are
polynomially equivalent to resolution
but the question is does this
equivalence also hold for cdcl
without restart so this question remains
open
but we came up with some
weaker results so the first theorem we
proved was consider the following
configuration of the cdcl sat solvers we
have cdcl conflict clause learning
with an asserting learning scheme
backtracking
non-deterministic variable selection
randomized value selection and restarts
and the same configuration without
restarts and we were able to show a
separation on a class of satisfiable
instances
we refer to as ladder formulas and
similarly we were able to look at two
configurations which are much more
realistic so cdcl with back jumping
v6 variable selection phase saving value
selection
and restarts in the same configuration
without the restarts
and here we were able to show a
separation again exponential separation
where restarts is more powerful than
without restarts on a class of
unsatisfiable instances referred to as
pitfall formulas
and just to give you an intuition behind
theorem 2
the way this proof works is that
without restart the solver gets stuck in
a
large space where the only way it can
get out of it is by making
constructing an exponential proof but if
it performs restarts it's able to get
out of that
much more quickly so that's kind of the
basic idea
now here i'm going to propose some
directions in which we can
instead of applying theory to practice
how about we go the other direction can
we apply practice to theory and solve
some interesting questions and
complexity theory using sat solvers
and i can identify a few directions that
might be quite interesting one direction
that i find particularly interesting is
solving
concrete circuit complexity questions
using using solvers
ryan williams posted the about problem
of some variant of double problem or as
a polymath problem on discord
and here the the question basically is
what's the minimum number of
multiplications needed
uh for three by three boolean matrix
multiplication is it 19
20 21 or 22 right so that's the open
problem
and there are innumerable such problems
that one could solve using solvers
uh another direction is that
practitioners have come up with new
proof system like
d-rat-based proof system so more
generally what i think
marine used to refer to as
interference-based proof systems
and these are inspired by practice and
uh can we prove lower bounds for them
uh yet another direction that might be
very interesting
is the following so if you think about
the work of a proof complexity theorist
part of the work is to come up with
conjectured classes of instances that
might be hard for a proof system
it's no easy task to come up with such
classes of instances
if you had a solver that could be a tool
that the
the theorists could use to rule out
so they might say oh yeah i know this
class of instances might be great why
don't i run it
on the solver and see what happens and
if the solver is able to quickly
show that these formulas are unset then
you say oh no this is not working i mean
you know i have to go back to the
drawing board and try something else
so such a tool doesn't exist and i'm
thinking of
making such a tool and would be great to
collaborate with the theorists to know
what they really want so we can build a
tool to their specification
uh finally uh solving combinatorics
problems yes that's always and i think
mariah talked about
quite a bit and i have also worked in
this place where in this space where we
combine sat solvers with computer
algebra systems
just like in dplt but we have dpll gas
to solve a variety of problems and
common networks
so open problems i already talked about
the first
three i'm i'm going to now briefly talk
about the last few
can we come up with a tighter upper
bound on the bcp algorithm to the extent
that i know
there is no complexity theoretic
analysis of the two watched little
scheme
maybe i'm missing something but at least
i haven't read it
from a practical point of view um
more machine learning heuristics for
solvers like can we come up with a
machine learning based
clause learning scheme as opposed to the
first uip which is kind of a hard-coded
uh
or a fixed uh heuristic it would be nice
to have more of a dynamic heuristic
yet another solver feature that i know
that users like
would be given an encoding of a problem
can i give some feedback to the user
saying this is why the encoding is not
working
you should try to fix this aspect of the
encoding
for this we need to have a theory of
encoding that will give us a way to
think about
uh good and bad encodings and then we
can encode that we can
code it up in the solver and give
feedback to the user for example
consistency is one idea
that you know if your encoding is you
can somehow detect that encoding is not
consistent
are consistent then you can give some
feedback to the user about it
uh another kind of class of uh
instances that are hard for solvers is
you know multiplication circuits
analyzing multiplication circuits so
we'll be nice to have solvers that are
better at this task
and now i will conclude with giving you
an overview of the workshop talks
uh for this entire 14-week workshop and
here is the first i think about nine or
so
of the scheduled workshop talks so the
first
week today is kind of giving you some
context some direction and open
problems like david is going to talk
about using
structure as a way to improve solver
performance and lauren is going to
i think talk about uh negative results i
don't know exactly i don't recall
exactly what he's going to talk about
next week is going to be theory and
practice of structure of sat instances
by stefan zeider jody levy ralph
rothenberg
followed by theory and practice of
encoding so this is you know how can we
use ideas
that cp people are very familiar with
but bring it into the context of sat
like oliver coleman shiran makrishan
maria banay march 3rd is going to be a
proof complexity toolbox so here we talk
about automatability and lifting
ideas uh which are there quite a few
papers in stock and fox in recent years
and this would be by robert robert
suzanne there
uh march 10th would be recent advances
in proof complexity of solvers so mark
menials noah fleming and ian lee
would talk about some of the restart
results i mentioned as well as uh
complexity theoretical results with
regard to branching heuristics
march 17th will be non-cdcl solvers so
solvers such as pseudo boolean solvers
and other solvers that have rich uh
pre-processing and processing techniques
uh by marijuana jacob nordstrom and joey
zhang
uh march 24th maria and daniel will talk
about
kind of lifting ideas from the cdcl
setting to the theater improver setting
march 31st is a public lecture the
richard m carp public lecture and
april 7th would be machine learning for
solvers
and we have still i think another
six or so weeks left after this so
if you have any suggestions please do
send it
our way and we'll be more than happy to
take that into account
so with that i'll end my talk and thank
you for your attention
thank you so much anybody has
any questions comments suggestions
i have a question
so you know bcp is really
in some sense hormone sat right
in some sense what horn sucks you can
think of
bcp is essentially sat unit propagation
coincidence yeah hornstart we know his
piece
is p time complete yeah
so when you say complete analysis of bcp
what exactly are you
are you thinking about i'm talking about
the
analysis of the two watch literal scheme
so
it is efficient for some reason um
but it would be nice to have maybe an
amortized analysis of it for example
um it would be nice to get an upper
bound essentially
which is uh less than n squared or
n times m um that's what i mean
okay refined with more refined analysis
okay exactly
yeah got you yeah
more questions comments
actually just to say something quickly
uh vijay mentioned
that on february 24th we will have
encoding showcase what it is if you've
had experience with some
interesting encoding of an interesting
class of instances
that you don't mind sharing something
very short
five ten minutes uh
please let me know and uh we are looking
for
interesting uh for interesting and the
showcase of interest and codings
okay more questions comments before we
go into next speaker and i shortly ask
about
reinforcement learning representation of
the problem
yeah that you mentioned before so what
is um
uh what is the objective there and what
are we optimizing
right so the objective there is what we
refer to as global learning rate so the
goal is to
maximize the number of conflicts you
learn by minimizing the number of
decisions that you have to make
and it seems like a very good objective
to optimize for
empirically we've shown that this
actually helps a lot
and that's the objective that we
optimize for
and and practically how many um of this
um
instances that you you need to give to
the proof system
how many of them you need to learn
properly
yeah so this is more of an online uh
learning method
um uh so it's not like an offline
method so yeah
okay so therefore you don't need to
train it offline
sorry when do you start improving
well it's uh you can think of it as uh
so there are many kind of online methods
that don't require you to
train ahead of time and these are
particularly useful in these kind of
settings where you have to make a quick
and cheap decisions
so yeah and it so happens that you know
these
the method that we came up with has this
very localized behavior
that matches the kind of instances that
we have the instances that have these
localized proofs of course we don't have
a proof of
a theorem to do this connection but this
is the intuition we have
okay i see i see it's local it's okay
okay thank you
thank you um
if there is nobody may i ask a question
yes please
so you uh you did talk about your
practice to theory direction
and use set solvers to
find combinatorial objects
without doing all without doing as much
of the hard work as we usually do
so what would be good examples that you
are thinking of
is particular for lower bounds for
theories
so um
so for example you know kind of
generating clauses of
instances and uh
if you had an idea that you think that
this
class of instances could be a lower
bound for resolution
you could generate it using the
generator test it against a solver
play with the knobs in the solver to see
if there is an easy way to solve it
and if there is an easy way to solve
then you can rule out that class of
instances right
so that's the the value of such a tool
but for that you know yeah so that is
also related to the
polymath problem that ryan posted about
finding i think it's a little bit
different so in the polymath problem
there
there's a specific concrete circuit
complexity question
how many multiplications what's the
minimum number of multiplications you
need to
solve the three by three boolean matrix
multiplication problem
and then you can encode that as a query
to the solver and ask
is it 17 uh sorry
1920 or 21. so that's a little bit
different from the other idea but
i can take it offlando thank you again